hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast tackling the challenge of FFPE
DNA extraction an automation ready
solution designed with an energy F focus
I in Christina mahalik of lab recom and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries and sponsored by assessment
culture life sciences next-generation
sequencing sample preparation and other
genomic workloads involve many tedious
and error-prone stats button and culture
life sciences automation and genomics
business units work with customers to
develop individualized solutions to help
accelerate workflows and achieve more
reliable results the company's portfolio
of genomic products currently include
nucleic acid extraction and purification
it's built on a patented solid phase
reversible immobilization spray
technology spry is a high-performance
nucleic acid purification technology
using paramagnetic fees to selectively
immobilize nucleic acids by type and
size optimize binding conditions allow
for highly specific separation and clean
that protocols we have a few important
announcements before we began this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window and if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your person
patient window or submit your problem
through the green Q&A button on the
lower left corner of the screen this is
an educational webinar and this offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
see e button located in the bottom left
hand corner of your webpage and follow
the process of obtaining your credit I
would now like to introduce today's
speakers CAF eight-month-old PhD staff
scientist second cultural life sciences
Kathy has more than 15 years of
molecular biology experience
she is currently a staff scientist at
Beckman Coulter life sciences
researching and developing genomic
reagent Kathy received her undergraduate
degree from Lycoming College Masters of
Science degree from the University of
Georgia and PhD from Cornell University
I will now turn it over to dr. Moss both
for her presentation such a month old
the floor is yours
good morning and thanks Christina for
the introduction and thank you all for
attending today's webinar on
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissue
challenging samples and cancer research
so today for this educational webinar
i'm going to talk to you a little bit
about what formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue is and why it's
important especially to cancer
researchers and then i'll go on to
discuss some of the opportunities and
challenges associated with this sample
type I'll move along to discussing DNA
extraction from FFP for genomic
sequencing and the importance of yield
purity and quality and the impact of
those on downstream applications like
next-generation sequencing and then I'll
conclude the talk with our development
journey into a robust and yet flexible
DNA extraction chemistry and workflow
and provide some data that supports this
development so what is formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue
well this sample type usually is occurs
after a biopsy is taken which is often
used to determine whether a patient has
cancer so after the biopsy the tissue is
fixed in formalin which is basically
just a solution of formaldehyde and the
formaldehyde fixes the tissue in place
both macroscopically and all the way
down to the molecular level and it
preserves the tissue and doesn't allow
it to decompose as if it was as it would
if it was unfixed after the fixation the
tissues dehydrated and then infiltrated
with paraffin and paraffin is just
simply a wax that provides support to
the tissue and this is important for
being able to take very thin slices of
the tissue with an instrument called a
microtome and that's shown here and
instrument can precisely slice the
samples into slices just a few microns
thick these slices can be mounted on
slides and stained with different
staining techniques to allow clinicians
to determine whether a patient's tumor
is cancerous or not and even the grade
of the cancer that might be present and
that's shown here by this micrograph
so another important aspect of this
sample type is that it doesn't require
special storage conditions it can be
stored at room temperature or more
preferably at 4 degrees and it can be
stored in quite high density situation
and it can be preserved for years upon
years and accessed later in time so this
sample type is of course important to
cancer researchers for determining if
cancer is present but if we can lock the
genomic information that's present in
these sample types then cancer
researchers can match the mutations that
might be present in that cancer with the
type of cancer and it's histology and
this really unlocks a powerful tool to
drive precision medicine and that allows
doctors to give patients more targeted
therapies towards the mutations that are
present in their cancer and these types
of chemo therapies can be more effective
and also have less side effects compared
with a generalized chemotherapy it's
important to note that this has really
taken off in say the last 10 years and
that is partially due to the advent of
next-gen sequencing technologies which
takes advantage of sequencing really
short reads so this type of DNA that you
extract from these samples can tend to
be a smaller size but it's not affected
in NGS sequencing because you're just
compiling a short reads a punch or reads
another improvement
that is really benefit benefitted this
field is that the library construction
methods that are required for next-gen
sequencing have really improved over the
years and allows researchers to use far
less input than was initially required
so FFP samples have been processed for
over a hundred years and back in the
late 1800s no one was really thinking
about well I might want to sequence
these samples and determine their
mutation spectrum because sequencing
really didn't take off until the 1970s
and because of this there are some
challenges to overcome when dealing with
these sample types and extracting DNA so
formalin causes DNA cross-linking and
that's important for the fixation and
the preservation of these samples but it
can also cause fragmentation and base
pair modifications and these are all
challenges to overcome when looking to
sequence these samples so I want to talk
a little bit about the main hurdle and
that's the cross-linking so DNA exists
in its double helical form but it
doesn't just flow freely in the cell
many of us know that it's packaged
around histones and these are proteins
that the DNA is wound tightly around and
then those histones are further packaged
into two or these nucleosomes or further
packaged into chromatin and make up the
chromosome so when the fixative hits the
tissue it actually forms covalent bonds
between the proteins and the DNA as well
as between the DNA and other DNA that it
might be close to so in order to utilize
the tissue we're utilize the DNA once
you pull it out of the tissue you need
to remove these covalent bonds otherwise
polymer aces won't be able to proceed
and
synthesize new DNA from the DNA so I've
talked a little bit about the cross
linking a challenge and I've mentioned
that this can inhibit polymerase
activity it can also inhibit the
denaturation of the DNA during PCR and
because of this it can reduce the
library yield so there are some
mitigation strategies that help in
overcoming these hurdles one is to
optimize the lysis and D cross linking
method and really get rid of all the D
cross links the cross links that are
that are possible to remove in in the
DNA another mitigation strategy would
too would be to look at the quality of
your DNA ahead of time how is it going
to perform in something like PCR and
there are various tools that I'll touch
upon in a few minutes to do just this so
another challenge is damage to the bases
within the DNA that occurs due to the
formalin so formalin can over time
transition to formic acid and this
really affects the bases within the DNA
it can cause a basic sites where there's
just no base present along the DNA
backbone and so the polymerase can get
stalled at this point or even just put
in a base that doesn't match the base
that was present so this can lead to
artefactual mutations that might be
present although this usually occurs
randomly and can be taken care of with
bioinformatic methods so another issue
is that cytosines
can be deaminated into uracil and then
that uracil gets matched up with a T
when the polymerase comes across so you
get see the T transitions so again
artefactual mutations that might show up
in your sequencing but again these are
random some mitigations
- this - the damage that occurs is to
use modified fixation conditions
conditions that don't allow the formalin
to turn to formic acid as easily and
also to really look at your sample
storage conditions to make sure that
you're using optimal storage some
companies have actually produced enzymes
that are able to repair some of this
damage one is uracil DNA glycosylase or
udg and this enzyme removes the uracil
that came from the deamination of
cytosine and then if paired with a
cocktail of enzymes there can be others
that add back the correct base into the
into that a basic site so any B has a an
enzyme cocktail that does just this
so the third major challenge with this
type of tissue is fragmentation and
fragmentation can of the DNA can just
exist within the sample itself but it
can also happen during the extraction
process and this can if if the
fragmentation exists in in a very if
there's a lot of fragmentation present
then this can reduce the library yield
and even reduce your ability to detect
mutations in the sample but again by
optimizing the D cross-linking and lysis
method you can overcome some of this
problem as well as looking at the
quality prior to library construction
and knowing what type of sample you're
dealing with so it's often thought that
it's just the age of the FFPE tissue
that is predictive of whether it'll
perform well in NGS or not but really
there are other aspects to consider so
like I mentioned earlier it's the sample
storage conditions the fixation
conditions to begin with are really
important as well as the extraction
method that you choose for your samples
so with all these challenges can they
really be mitigated to produce high
quality NGS data and if we look in the
literature we do find that there are
quite a few publications that compare
fresh frozen tissue to FFPE tissue and
the extracted DNA can give similar
results from from both types of tissue
so so there is evidence out there that
it is a great sample type and there are
actually millions of these samples that
are stored in bio banks and hospitals
around the world so being able to access
this information that's stored in them
and the corresponding clinical
information about various types of
cancers that might be present also
allows researchers to make connections
between what types of mutations caused
cancer so it's really a powerful system
for doing cancer research so I've told
you a little bit about the challenges
that you face when you're trying to
extract DNA and use it for NGS
downstream so I want to go over some of
the quality tools that are available to
researchers and how we can look at yield
purity and yields purity and quality
with those so I'll start here by sharing
two different methods that can be used
to determine the yield that's in your
DNA after it's been extracted on the
Left we have a nano-sim nanodrop results
and this is a spectrophotometric assay
for determining concentration of DNA and
on the right we have Pico green and this
is a fluorescence based assay that
utilizes a dye that bind double-stranded
DNA and what you'll notice is that with
the nanodrop we get much higher
concentrations than we do with a Pico
green
day and that's because the nanodrop
measures the total DNA content within
your sample whether it's single-stranded
or double stranded whereas Pico green
measures the double-stranded content and
this is important for some library
construction methods which require
double-stranded DNA to add adapters
during library construction so if you're
going to use an assay or a downstream
application that requires
double-stranded DNA it's always better
to go with Pico green you'll also notice
that when RNA is removed from the
workflow an RNA would then be present in
the sample it inflates the nanodrop
readings by more than double and in the
case of Pico green which should be
specific to double-stranded DNA there
also is somewhat of an inflation of of
the concentrations so if you ever so
it's important to remember that when if
you don't want to use RNA sand your
samples another aspect of quality that
we look at is purity and so the nanodrop
does a really good job of this and we
can look at different ratios of
absorbance usually at 260 280 which is
shown here in the light blue and 260 230
shown in the dark blue so the 260 280
ratio gives you an idea if you have
contaminating proteins present in your
sample and for pure DNA this ratio
should be around 1.8 and you can see
that most of these tissues are falling
right around there or most of this DNA
the 250 to 30 ratio gives you an
indication of whether your sample is
contaminated with other contaminants
that might absorb at 230 and this
includes salt among others and this
tends to be somewhere where FFPE tissue
is is known to have lower to 6230 ratios
but pure DNA would be around 2 so this
is another way to assess your DNA how
well your extraction performed you can
also look at the distribution of
fragments within your sample so
fragmentation does occur within FFP
tissue and you can expect many times
that you might see a profile like the
one on the left so this is DNA that's
been extracted from a tumor ssp tissue
source and you can see that the peak of
the fragment is around three thousand
base pairs and the distribution is is
pretty broad on the right we have a an
SF PE reference tissue so this is a
really high quality tissue that's been
optimized to get really nice DNA out of
and here you can see that that
distribution is very narrow at greater
than sixty thousand base pairs in these
tape station traces so you can expect to
see wide variability within FFPE samples
from block to block you can also see
differences in your quality assessments
even moving through the block from one
end to the other and so the final tool
that I'd like to discuss for determining
quality is a using qpcr so I've told you
that the cross-linking can be a real
problem for polymerase a--'s to the
point where they stall if they hit a
point where a protein is still
cross-linked and can't proceed and
amplify the DNA
so using qpcr gives you an indication of
whether that's a problem in your sample
this particular assay utilizes the
amplification
a short fragment to give you some idea
of just your quantification of the DNA
that's present in the sample and then it
compares the short fragment
amplification to that of longer
fragments 129 base pair and a 305 base
pair and as you look at those ratios you
can tell how easily the polymerase can
access the DNA and into what length so
on the left here we have that horizon
reference tissue which has really
high-quality DNA and you can see that
the ratio of the 1 29 to 41 fragment is
pretty high around 0.8 and even as as
you move toward the ratio of the 305 to
41 fragment that ratio is maintained at
point II when we look at actual blocks
of FFPE tissue we again see this wide
variability in this case the ratio of
the 1 29 to 41 fragment is giving us
still a pretty good ratio for FFP tissue
of 0.6 but then at 305 241 ratio drops
down to point to telling us that there's
something about this particular sample
that doesn't allow the polymerase to
really extend much further into that 305
fragment so with all of these different
quality tools that researchers have at
hand to assess their DNA they can give
you an idea of how your sample might
perform in library construction for
downstream sequencing but really it is
going through the library construction
itself and looking at the quality of the
library that is the most indicative of
what your results are going to look like
at the end so many researchers use
combinations of these 1 or 2 some just
make the library because these samples
are so valuable they may not be able to
get another biopsy for instance so you
just go right into sequencing and you
get what you get
so this field is really a burgeoning
field in fact there's been almost 30%
growth in the number of samples that
have been analyzed since 2013 but what
we find when we talk to researchers is
that only about 50% of them are
satisfied with their current DNA
extraction method from FFP tissue so
that tells us that there is a lot of
room for improvement in this space and
of those who are interested in switching
only about 20 of them have switched
recently telling us again lots of room
for improvement in the methodologies for
extracting DNA so when we did talk to
researchers we learned some interesting
things about what was most important to
them yield is the number one factor in
looking at an extraction chemistry and
purity and quality are also really
important and how how the DNA from
functions in downstream sequencing is
also important
total purification time and the hands-on
time required and its compatibility with
automation are another another subset of
items that are really important to
researchers and if they're able to
reduce the amount of time they spent on
extraction and then they can free up
researchers to do other work in the lab
and a one more thing that was important
was the avoidance of hazardous chemicals
so typically and historically FFPE
samples have been de Paris on eyes so
the the wax is removed before you can
get us the DNA d paraffin eyes with
xylene and silane is an organic compound
that is just really hazardous and to
work with so this was another concern
and we also found that flexibility is
important to many labs so some labs will
have an ebb and flow in the number of
samples that are coming in to the lab so
at some times they may just have 20
samples per week and maybe a manual
workflow would be more effective for
them at other times they might end up
with 500 samples per week and so an
automated workflow is really important
and being able to move between these two
easily and still maintain the high yield
and high quality that's optimized for
NGS workflows is the most important
factor so although there are some
automated solutions available currently
many of them are only semi automated so
they begin after the the DP organization
step or even just for finding the DNA
washing and eluding it so we wanted to
to focus we know that that customers are
really interested in a fully automated
workflow so knowing what customers and
researchers were interested in we set
out to develop a robust and flexible DNA
extraction chemistry and workflow so now
I'll describe the workflow and a little
bit about how we optimize the chemistry
and the data that we generated during
development so our major goals were to
create a really simple to use product
and that meant minimizing the total
number of steps that are required in the
extraction we also wanted to minimize
the centrifugation steps and this is
important when transferring a manual
process to automation
and it allows you to to work in a much
higher throughput manner when a
centrifuge is not involved we wanted to
minimize the temperature changes and
eliminate hazardous chemicals and many
of the solutions that are currently
available our spin column and there's a
recognised risk of clogging of those
columns if the tissue isn't digested
enough or if too much input is added to
the sample so we wanted to use a
chemistry that didn't have this
challenge so we came up with a pretty
simplified workflow most workflows have
several steps so I'll run through those
first is the D paraffin ization step to
remove the paraffin than a lysis step
where an enzyme chews up the protein
followed by ad cross-linking step to
remove those cross-links RNA is
typically included to degrade the RNA
present in the sample a binding step
followed by a washing step to eliminate
all the contaminants and then Ellucian
so we went through each of these steps
and optimized each one for the best
performance possible in the de paraffin
ization step shown here
we used a a non hazardous component in
this case it's mineral oil to remove the
paraffin from the sample and the mineral
oil actually plays two roles in the
chemistry it dissolves solubilizes the
paraffin and then in subsequent steps it
provides a barrier for evaporation so
that when you're automating the method
you don't have to worry about sealing
your plates during the long incubation
or high temperature incubation the next
step is lysis and here you would add
your lysis buffer
do the sample which sinks to the bottom
and carries the tissue with it and it's
in this lower phase where you as a PK
and the proteins are degraded and there
you can see the the mineral oil plank of
forming this evaporation barrier so
there is some flexibility provided at
this step we recommend a minimum of an
hour but it can go several hours or
overnight depending on how much life
this time you need to fully life the
sample then we're following it up with a
D cross-linking step and this is simply
heating it to a high temperature and
it's known that high temperatures can
reverse some of the cross links that are
many of the cross links that are formed
by formaldehyde fixation here again it's
important that this is a high
temperature step so it's about 90
degrees and there's a real balance here
between D cross-linking your sample and
degrading it so we we use 90 degrees as
a maximum but there is some flexibility
to reduce that temperature and make sure
you're getting the best quality possible
out of your samples in terms of D
cross-linking and there's a quick RNA
step at room temperature followed up by
the binding step so here to avoid that
clogging we talked about before we used
a bead based chemistry which is our Spri
technology to bind the DNA and because
FFPE extracted DNA can be fragmented we
wanted to be sure we were using a
binding chemistry that really grabbed
all the DNA out of the solution so even
though smaller fragments are bound by
this chemistry the beads are magnetic so
they can be pulled down pulled away from
the solution with a magnet the rest of
the lysate can be removed and then we we
made sure that we created a wash a
simple washing
oh gee so we created a wash buffer that
removes most of the contaminants in the
solution and then just follow that up
with an 80 percent ethanol wash that
removes any remaining wash buffer from
the sample as well as any remaining
contaminants and then we also provided
some flexibility in the aleutian step so
here you can elute provided you have a
low Ellucian magnet in as little as 20
to 25 microliters and of course you can
scale up the elution volume as much as
needed and you you can also use water or
at risk based elution buffer is also
sufficient so this workflow works really
nicely both with manual extraction which
it does have one centrifugation step but
it can be transferred to automation with
no centrifugation steps so once we had
or while we were developing this and
once we had the workflow in place we
wanted to make sure we were getting the
highest yields impurities possible with
these samples so there are quite a few
commercially available kits on the
market currently so we use those to
determine whether our yields were what
other researchers would expect to get
and that can be seen here on the left we
use various sample types and you can see
from block-to-block sample types of
sample type you get very different
results with a single slice of tissue a
10 micron flight and we found that we
were in some places better in some
places equal to commercially available
kits and then we also looked at the
purity in terms of the 260 280 and 260
230 ratios and this was a slide I showed
earlier but you can see that the ratios
looks really good for for this
extraction with different sample types
because we know that a lot of cancer
researchers want to use this DNA in
next-gen sequencing we really wanted to
be sure that our extraction method
wasn't going to affect the sequencing in
any way so one thing that can happen
with an extraction method is that you
could be biasing the part of the genome
that you're extracting with your
extraction method so one way to know
that that wasn't happening was to use
whole genome sequencing at low pass just
to look at the average GC content and
what we found for two samples shown here
is that we got 41% GC
so there was no bias toward high GC or
low GC content DNA after extraction with
our workflow in chemistry we also know
that cancer researchers often use excess
comp exome capture in their work so we
wanted to use this NGS platform to again
look at whether we were biasing
ourselves towards certain regions of the
genome and in order to do this we looked
at extracted DNA versus control DNA that
had not been extracted by our methods
and this is DNA that had come from
control cell line and you can see that
the libraries that were constructed
before the capture are very similar to
be extracted DNA versus the control DNA
and the pooled library also looks really
nice so so we're getting that peak at
300 base pairs as expected so the data
from our exome capture sequencing
revealed that for the controlled DNA
which is shown here on the bottom
compared with the extracted DNA
libraries we got basically the same
result in all of the metrics that we
tested here I'm showing you the
uniformity of coverage and you can see
that we are getting
the same results between the control DNA
and extracted DNA and same for the
target coverage at 1x 10x 20x and 50x so
again it doesn't look like we're biasing
what we're we're pulling out with our
extraction method and again we also know
that cancer researchers are often
focused on targeted amplicon sequencing
and looking for specific mutations
within cancer hotspots in the genome so
here we use an Amphicar based approach
and we sequence six libraries and found
that in all six libraries in so I should
back up and mention that what we
extracted the DNA from is a horizon
reference tissue and this reference
tissue has specific allele frequencies
for all these mutations shown here so
when we made libraries we found that in
all six libraries that we sequence we
identified the variants that were known
to be present in the sample and that's
the variant frequencies that we obtained
from our sequencing were very similar to
the expected frequencies that are known
to be present in in the tissue so this
just gives us more data to support that
this extraction chemistry is really
optimized for NGS technologies and
finally I've mentioned that we wanted to
focus on providing a fully automated
method for flexibility for cancer
researchers and this slide is just
showing that when the method is fully
automated from D paraffin ization all
the way through Ellucian we get
basically the same result as you would
when you're using it manually so here
we're showing double-stranded DNA
to 6230 ratios and to 6280 ratios and
those are very similar for both
automation and manual extraction this
was that data was produced on the
biomech 4000 so this is a more simple
type of liquid handler that can handle
about 24 samples at a time the fully
automated method only takes about 15
minutes of hands-on time at the start
and it can process 24 samples in about
four hours we also have a higher
throughput method that we've automated
on our biomech biomech FXP and again
this is a fully automated method from
depersonalization to elution
and it takes only about 15 minutes of
set-up time and it can run through 96
samples and about 5.5 hours so I should
back up and mention that manually we can
run through about 24 samples in four
hours as well so for the biomech 4000
it's the same timing but it frees up an
entire researchers four hours and in the
case of the FX it allows a lot of
freedom within the lab for researchers
to do other work and in the interest of
time we'll glaze over this this is just
to show that we have a demonstrated
method that's been verified on the bio
Mac okay so in summary I've talked to
you a little bit about the opportunities
and the challenges that are associated
with genomic sequencing of FFP extracted
DNA and I've walked you through our
development process and shown that we've
really created a workflow and a
chemistry that it gives great results
for yield and purity and functions and
is really optimized for NGS
downstream applications so we now have a
new product and the data that I've
presented today this product is
commercially available and the data I
presented today was all generated with
this product so with that I would like
to thank you for your attention and to
mention that this work was not done in
isolation by me so I'd like to thank the
entire Beckman R&D team that worked so
hard on this project and take any
questions that you might have thank you
Thank You dr. Michael for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can so here we go
question 1 how much yield do I need for
successful in GF well that's a really
good question and something we we
certainly spend a lot of time thinking
about us we tested the different NGS
methods with our extracted DNA and many
factors govern the input requirements
for library construction one of the
first ones is what question are you
trying to answer is it a variant
detection in your sample and if that is
the case then you need to think about
what is the expected frequency of the
variant and possibly the percent of
tumor that went into your sample so so
if you have a low percent of tumor you
might need to increase the B input then
so you're sure you're sequencing the
variants that you're hoping to detect
another consideration is what type of
sequencing are you doing so is it the
whole genome sequencing whole exome
sequencing or possibly amplicon so with
something like targeted amplicon you may
not need quite as much input as you
would for other types of sequencing and
finally it's again going back to the
quality issue with this DNA it's
important to consider that so if you
have lower quality DNA it might require
more input and then finally thinking
about your particular library
construction kit many of those will have
input requirements
did and if they're not specifically
suggested for FFPE you may need to
increase the amount of input you put in
or you can contact their tech support
lines they're often very helpful
explored thank you so much for that
information let's see our second
question today asked if I wanted to
evaluate forma pier or DNA chemistry who
do I who should I contact well that's a
great question in fact we can put up a
poll right now so if you're interested
in evaluating you can click yes and
someone from Beck Beck men will get into
contact with you to let you know how you
can can get yourself some - to test out
but in the future you if you're not
interested now but you are in the future
you can contact your local sales rep
from Beckman or just go through the
website excellent thank you we've got
some great questions today they keep
coming in if I wanted to evaluate forma
pure DNA chemists oh wait I just did
that one can you please expand on the
automated method timing yes and actually
I'm joined today by my colleague - Zack
Smith who's an application scientist for
automation so I'll let him feel that
question hi so I'm Zack and as far as
the automation timing is concerned for a
96 sample of processing time on the
biomech FX p we're looking at about five
and a half hours I would like to note
that a lot of that time is incubation
time so there's not a huge amount that
the automation can speed up as far as
like the number of samples being
processed so for example you're going to
process you know 24 samples and
approximately 4 hours and 45 minutes of
machine time so on the other hand you do
get a lot of you know time savings when
you consider the number of samples being
processed for 24 to 90
so it the FX takes advantage of the fact
that it is a dual pod liquid handler and
we use that multi-channel pod we're
doing like full plate transfers for
example while we're using the span pod
for dimming reagent aliquot Eng for the
wash buffers and whatnot so that we're
reducing as much as possible the amount
of reagent that's required for the
number of samples big process so trying
to make most efficient use of your kids
and your time thank you so much for that
answer our next question is how much
tissue should I use to get sufficient
DNA for my NGS application another great
question again this is going to kind of
depend on your particular application it
can depend on again if you're looking
for a particular variant the percent
tumor that's present in the FFP ice that
you're using and the quality of the
block but we generally recommend as a
just a basic starting point is to test
out 110 microns section see what you get
and then adjust from there excellent
thank you another great question is the
mineral oil purified removal step done
manually or on the same instrumentation
used to isolate DNA so all that handle
this assure the automation right so
during the course of doing the
automation development we we realized
that starting with the curls themselves
was really what people wanted to do they
wanted to be able to just load the curls
up in a tube or plate and put them
directly on the deck and let the
instrumentation handle it for that
purpose we developed a new tube rack
that allows us to put one point 4 ml
matrix tubes directly in a 96-well
format but the tube rack itself is also
open on the bottom so we can move it on
and off with Peltier's for example when
we need to do our heating and cool
the tube rack also because the bottom is
open allows for the tubes to also take
advantage of the 2d barcodes that are
associated with those tubes so you can
scan a whole place worth of barcodes so
that you have the sample a sectioning
required for your your samples once your
processing so basically for the
automation solution you load your curls
up in these tubes you put the tubes in
the tube rack and the mineral oil
addition is handled and lysis is handled
on deck once the license is complete the
the biomat goes through and pipettes
underneath underneath the emitter oil
layer and transfers the lysate to a new
plate leaving the mineral oil behind the
original tubes okay and how do you renew
the mineral oil is it pitted or soluble
in the damaged stream wash buffer so
kind of piggybacking on that previous
question the the mineral oil is left
behind in the original lysis tube and we
transfer the lysate into a fresh plate
so there's a two phase separation where
the mineral oil is always on top and the
light base on the bottom and how how do
you improve 2060 2030 ration in in the
workflow okay so the the two 6230 ratio
is it's tricky and we we spent a lot of
time improving this particular metric
and and mostly it was through
optimization of our washing strategy or
wash buffer that's provided in the kit
as well as the the downstream eighty
percent ethanol wash and from where we
started to where we ended we improved it
quite a bit but there is just some part
of that that's governed by the sample
and there's just such variability in
these samples that that remains the big
challenge with FFPE tissue
thank you excellent our next question is
I just missed them in the beginning can
I get a copy of the slides thank you
yes this webinar will be available for
download on the lab group website after
today so so you can always go back to it
and see what you missed wonderful
oK we've still got some more great
questions coming in how do you recover
odor FFPE samples with over fix in
extensively cross-linked yeah that's a
real challenge
so with those of course here you may
need to optimize your license time and
so so maybe you need to take a little
longer to degrade the proteins that are
present and allow for the D
cross-linking to be a little bit more
effective and this is certainly an
optimizable step that we've gone all the
way to overnight for our lysis
conditions with with really good results
you can also I mean if it's if it's
super cross-linked and you need to
further decrease linkit you could go
longer i wouldn't recommend going higher
on the temperature during the the d
cross-linking but that's something that
you might be able to track with a to pcr
assay to determine if this is really
helping your situation or not I would
just like to add as far as the
automation solution is concerned all of
those variables as she was considered
that Kathy was talking about modifying
are you can modify them in the user
interface of the method when the method
launches it defaults to the to the kits
recommended times and temperatures but
all those all those variable all those
times and temperatures are optional as
well so I thank you for that information
our follow up question oh this is great
what is the minimum look this time we
and one hour for for a starting point
it works well for for most samples and
then we recommend extending from there
if you have hard to digest tissue or
maybe increased input like more slices
in a sample thank you
our next question asks do you have FFPE
RNA extraction kits if so are they
manual or automated we do have a kit
that is is for RNA extraction from FFP
it's just called form up here and and
this has been available for for a while
and that can be automated right the
current for mature method is automated
we're right now we are in the one of my
other colleagues is in the process of
trying to sort of take what we've
learned with the farm pure DNA
automation solution and apply it to the
farm pure RNA solution so you to put
your curls straight on the deck so that
work is currently ongoing we do have a
good solid base method to work off of so
thank you excellent looks like we have
one more question coming in looks like
it reads with the manual method how is
the magnet used to extract the bead so
the the Frye beads that we use in many
of our our chemistry's if not all have a
magnetite core so the magnet just pulls
them right out of the solution to the
magnet for a plate is usually a ring on
the bottom of your well and so it pulls
those these out of solution right to the
ring on the well at the bottom of the
well and then you can use your pipette
in the center to remove the liquid and
and then carry on with the protocol and
then we do have some magnets for in tube
format which pulls the beads then to the
side of the tube
thank you dr. mark fold up I just want
to let everyone know that we are running
short on time so that will be our last
question for today however I do want to
let everyone know our audience that if
you have any follow-up questions you may
do so once you after the webinar you can
go to the webinar watch it and submit
your questions that way as well once
again I would like to thank dr. muffled
and you have any final comments that
you'd like to wrap up with today um no I
think we pretty much covered everything
I just want to thank everybody again for
attending this webinar thank you so much
for your time as well I would also like
to thank our sponsor Beckman culture and
life sciences for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September 2017 you will
receive an email from Lavery's
alerting you when this webcast is
available for replay we invite you to
Ford this announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event we will see you next time
here at labrie goodbye